but you only think that this thing is
going to be the thing I always thought
like okay disappearance on Jimmy Fallon
is going to be the thing right or or
this podcast like Rogen is going to be
the thing or or this person following me
on on social media is going to be the
thing none of us the thing it's just
another block another stepping stool and
the quicker you think about like bricks
instead of like a prefab building the
quicker you win macro mom doesn't not a
gravel some background Axl Michael is
like a visible what I see with clarity
like my name is Gary Thomas I've been
telling you accounts of equity
I'm triple a given a pedigree second
being in a fleshly specialty including
the work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture happen when do we when do we
go on the offense on the new class up
immediately the guys I'm going to go
second program after after we signed
this guy that were signing next week
clock dropping means you have a nice and
watch it coming studio and on and how
their thank you big this good yeah
that's funny not good okay sunday 7 or
does it just look out
work quick does that Sunday I'm telling
you right now if your startup brand if I
mean this is just this is a commercial
inside of daily be if you're a startup
brand and you really want to get into
the sports game you should hit us up put
the email down here Tyler
visited Sunday not for the product we're
looking for dollars you know five ten
fifteen hundred thousand dollar deals
for our athletes but what we'll be able
to do above and beyond the exposure of
having NFL rookie that you can build
with is a relationship with me us and
and the things we'll do in this campaign
so we get a bunch of brands for the
first visit of Sunday they are super
pumped we're happy and we're going to
have a big class make sure you have a
lot going on this is exactly time to hit
up this def Sunday if you know there's
sir I think I think certain categories
already done right like we can't do yeah
like player by player got okay
but like yeah you'll regret it
that's incredible great is about to get
really bad
it's vehicles wait ah this exact but I
have a funny feeling the right thing to
do is to have people check their egos at
the door yeah I just think we have to
break our reality it's time for me to
break it's my job you type of man real
tight as well - Oh real pleasure
you know I think that getting into a
market is actually stunningly easy
so I actually genuinely believe you take
the advice about the ginyu it will work
I'm surprised how many people overthink
it I think you can map every single
buying decision makers in America and I
think you can email them hit them up at
social media and then surprise and
delight them like it's literally that
basic like you actually know the five
thousand stores distribution centers you
want to be in like right and fear you
know like you want to be an urban output
this hunter knows you want to be in this
little Soho shop I don't know that's
your business
I don't know it so divide a wine I sure
know which stores right so great you
decide there's 41 motifs and so how you
want to define you guys sit on [ __ ]
Google find the person's name send them
a t-shirts and the note in the mail they
give millions of that picture on a
garbage of same way I do right you email
them you follow them on Twitter and
Instagram you talk to them on Twitter
and Instagram you tagged them in some of
your photos on Instagram so it shows up
in their notifications you one-on-one
virtually sell the fifteen hundred and
thirty seven people that make the
decision if this t-shirt goes on a rack
as you are you know in the last 100 days
last four months it's really starting to
pop for me right and it was like you
know how come this is happening I'm like
20 [ __ ] years of [ __ ] hustle dick
that's why it's happening you know what
I mean you never know when it's going to
be that moment so look this is smart you
got here this is [ __ ] Queen great
exposure there's cool people that watch
great good [ __ ] could happen but you
only think that this thing is going to
be the thing I always thought like okay
disappearance on Jimmy Fallon is going
to be the thing right or or this podcast
with Rogen is going to be the thing or
or this person following me on on social
media is going to be the thing none of
it's the thing it's just another block
another stepping store and the quicker
you think about like bricks instead of
like a prefab building the quicker you
win
I'm being dead serious man you've got to
know that missing 11 times and hitting
the one time of the 12 times that you
start 12 hours on is ROI positive that's
one note these [ __ ] don't get no
buyers buyers or get it go on the ground
fires you kick on the ground what are
gonna buy $4,000 [ __ ] Australian
flight ticket and Trek you don't have
that you're gonna build an empire from
your bed ready I own your business
Australia spend two days with my team if
the videos Austin Boston known today
you're not video today you're [ __ ] on
Google Google top [ __ ] [ __ ] clothing
stores in Australia rad clothing stores
in Australia go to in ceramic hash tag
Australian clothing Australian store
let's [ __ ] work on spec get a list
okay here 239 shops we want to be a part
of on the East Coast okay now we go to
their website scroll down contact about
me about me
Carl tint Anton started this because his
dad loved these co6 Google Carl
Templeton Carl loves Australian rules
football like like [ __ ] it work then
email and say yo Carl sorry your team
lost last night you know did the digital
then you DM him then you leave a comment
on one of his Instagram posting email
him email his website leave a comment on
a post he made on Instagram and at him
on Twitter you guys following the work
got it so that's what you do what three
of those 39 people say yeah
send me a shirt one of those three that
you sent is sure to put it in their
store one really smoke show model walks
in there where is it and away you go
it's a name well I think it starts with
you doing the right behavior so the
reason I'm always confident is I know
I'm doing the right behavior so you
everybody here can blame me or this map
but I'm very comfortable that I've
created the right behavior and that over
time whether they believe in me now or
over the long term that I'll win that
game so I think it starts with you so
for example I think it's less about
because maybe you're emotionally
intelligent and you like that space that
you're going to coach them up or down or
left and right I think it's you showing
your lack of insecurity and building
confidence with everybody up down left
and right around you such a pleasure
how are you you're great like your
t-shirt thank you what I really
appreciated about the meeting and what
what sort of society is that we know
getting to be
so type to have like very large opinion
about things and talk what what I really
liked about Gary is that he seemed very
different from when he speaks large
crowd when he's in a while overview he
wants to hear what you have to say and
so I just tell them you being here in my
it's all about playing they required for
me to tell myself how long you been here
eight months I'm from Atlanta eastward
please been doing search before that I
did PR sound been around for like five
six years I like again in the future so
PR fun but the second s are doing their
jobs like haha great data but I know if
I am to continue up so yeah question
yeah we're turning on right the second
or overall okay um just like executing
on the gratitude I have that I have all
this in making you know that's what's on
my mind
executing on the gratitude I have for
the things I was gifted with because I
know I'm different you know it's the
truth that's the most macro answer to
your question like I you know some
people are born all time great athletes
and you know singers
I just think that I can reinvent the way
businesses are built big ones and I want
to do that okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. [ __ ] sorry I'm late
good to see you all the way on the left
place thank you come on Bob our College
service is how to board video dr.
Scarsdale oh boy excuse me it's really
close how many people you should see
what's going on the other side I think
we have five we've 750 overall hey guys
okay net and so yeah it's pretty good
it's like I'm very big on on HR EQ all
that stuff if you go on YouTube right
now there's videos of me ten years ago
tasting wine right and it became huge to
the point where the Washington Post's
that I was the most influential wine
critic besides Robert Parker in the
world I became like it was really cool I
was some real wine guy
there's a crazy professor there that
would use my videos that I told you
about earlier there's the biggest wine
class in America is that Virginia Tech
for people that are seniors right or 21
and that'd be 21 and so he started using
my content because I was the most
relatable thing to anybody under 30 yes
when I was 15 years old I memorized
every Robert Parker score of every wine
ever okay yeah let's do that
okay Andy do me a favor have Tyler
introduce you guys on email just so it's
there
that famous alright didn't see it let's
make a boat or meaning you know is that
hello you two sleep together new school
yes every bar how do you look quite
remarkable right about many very poor
thing yeah and I'm supposed together
over up a big thing you know how you
doing we're just catching up damn
director / great that's the world you
know I want to be arrested David when
you think when you give the Nike when
you did when you're when you guys did
the adidas thing thing you guys were
ready or what's that mean yeah but I
watched the documentaries and I'm 41 I
was very well yeah I'm much older yeah
but that stuff you guys did was like I
would lived in Jersey like innate like I
was an 11 year old kid in New Jersey
when you guys are doing that stuff that
was interesting because that was the
first time a non-athlete things did that
kind of deal did that make you guys
radar that's what you guys have an
interesting crossover news I love you
pal
good to see you yeah I'll talk to you
again I'll see you soon hot all right
keep some thoughts when I said I will
pay me alright let's go hey where are we
going of course
have you been
[Music]
thanks man than that it is us whatever
you were here not at this office you
were here we just we moved here in
August you were here like a year ago
right before we mean balled up digital
yes that's right that's right that's
exactly right
hey guys I'm Gary Vaynerchuk from CEO of
vaynermedia Colorado where it was like I
was watching from afar trying to milk
every second
[Music]
Oh God everyone going how are you thank
you my man
Thank You Barney Miller I'm excited man
yes I I'm an artist I'm actually more
position than the artist but I started
painting a long time ago but I came
across your book and I started reading
an eye shadow great Schneider yes quite
close with him that's a little uh yeah
anybody was a Jets fan I know I figured
yeah he's also on it's awesome I read
your book and like it just it's boats a
lot of things that I was already
thinking so it's kind of inspired me so
I want to kind of paint this to you but
thank you good dude thank you man you
sound like my style like this kind of
splatter Fame this is incredible brother
that is really nice you made 17 of them
no no oh that's a date got it again
number three in 17 I miss oh you rock
where's Suzy Brock here you go get you
some exposure you're up look what you
got Wow shake the man's hand how you
doing a friend that I know started
working for Gary a long time ago before
I knew anything about like Gary or
anything and then recent in the past
like probably a year and a half I
actually came across Gary's book
askgaryvee just picked it up for some
reason I was like all right I'll look at
this you know want to learn more about
like entrepreneurship all that kind of
stuff just like what successful people
out straight read the whole thing and it
just like resonated with I guess how I
think of things so after I read this
book
yeah it just inspired me to do things in
a slightly different way with my art
that I just started doing the past year
figured I wanted to paint Garrity
because and give it to him sort of a
thank you so I just kind of painted a
portrait of him and then posted on
Twitter kid responded in like three
minutes he was like yeah I'll take it
and I was like holy [ __ ] and the entire
table we set this thing up and now like
I got to meet him because of that which
was just awesome you know I don't need
even Ross's
or Barry Diller's or Steve Jobs his
point of view because I only care about
what the market thing right now I don't
think I have I'm only yes to the market
I'm not the typical I think people
confused I don't think I have any
opinions I think I'm just reacting it's
you know I mean like I don't feel like
they're mine so I have no clue though in
that I don't need it like a closed group
of like yes you're the man right I don't
think they're mine
I think I'm an interpreter of it no yeah
I mean you just you know your friends
and your relationships and you engage in
them and you know I don't know I think
I'm pretty big on serendipity osmosis I
think people will think those things a
little bit
good day bunch of internal meetings with
senior leadership just client stuff
Russell Simmons Davis off Michael Jordan
Patrick Ewing's agent
Patrick Ewing made accountable the deck
as I'm sure to start talking about this
but when did you realize this is real
place
no just our business sort of like Satan
if they make it and you got to have
skill that you were fine but I was like
holy [ __ ] you withdraw my Saturday um
the thing with me is that if I'm
actually running a business it's a
foregone conclusion so it was really one
it was really Austin when I decided to
actually be the day-in day-out CEO and
then immediately knew we were going to
win like blind faith in my business
ability it was the second I knew I was
going to do it I knew was going to win
like just completely another blind faith
it's just what I'm good at
you know and again I'm not you
understand this is where people
completely don't understand me at all I
am NOT wrapped up in my own [ __ ] I look
like I am I get it
the reason I win so much is it's them
not me it's my popular it's Deb not me
if you guys not me now I know when I
have to have a responsibility to make
tough decisions or change your strategy
changes will be big on influencer
marketing Ruby's like I know what I have
of what I do but I don't need anybody to
make me feel good that's what y'all
don't get I'm the ultimate not insecure
person so I don't need it I don't care
if people think I'm the most humble or
the most ego they both feel the same to
me they're their people's interpretation
of the serendipity of the interactions
they have with me I'm empathetic to how
they got there I'm equally empathetic to
somebody who thinks I'm the greatest
genius to somebody thinking
the greatest snake oil salesmen like it
just I get it
which is then allows me to just go fast
just not thinking about that
I know I've good intent I know who I am
I'm whole inside
I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]